today we're gonna explain the full
backstory of Almighty the greatest hero
in the world of my hero academia and
with the greatest haircut to match but
before we begin don't forget to
subscribe to this channel as we're not
that far off a thousand subscribers I do
one video a week and would really
appreciate it if you would subscribe
okay let's get into it
all might was born at a time when people
without quirks were becoming more and
more uncommon but despite that he was
one of the unlucky few to be born with
no powers of his own during his
childhood all one was in his prime and
there was no true symbol to oppose him
this is the environment that fostered
almost desire to create a world where
people could live without fear but
obviously it's kind of hard to do that
when you're a skinny Quercus kid during
his early teenage years he encountered
the hero known as Nana shamora and told
her about his visions of becoming this
symbol of peace and we actually saw this
in a flashback in season 3 following
this at some point before all might turn
16 she decided to pass the power down to
him making him the eighth person to
possess the power and on that note
here's a little bit of trivia for you
all meit's real name is Toshi nori yogi
with the name yogi containing the kanji
for 8 which is kind of foreshadowing the
fact that he would indeed become the
eighth wielder also when he received
all-4-one he was actually able to use it
at a hundred percent right from the
beginning must be nice but bear in mind
that all my it's a hundred percent is
way different from deck who's 100
percent because due to the nature of one
for all and it's stockpiling ability
when Deku received it it was
significantly stronger than when all I
received it but still pretty cool to be
able to use the entire power just right
from the jump anyway a couple of years
passed by and all Mike was a final-year
student at U a but before he could
graduate he somehow became involved in a
massive battle with awful one from the
manga it's pretty clear that Nana
shamora knew this fight was about to
happen as just before it went down she
said goodbye to her son for the last
time almost like she knew she was gonna
die my guess is that they had some
intelligence that said the whole forum
was about to do something major and went
to confront him before it could take
place and if you look at this footage
from the buildings in the background we
can see that they were in fact fighting
in a city but from this shot it's also
pretty clear it was an island so an
island city I guess perhaps quite
similar to the one we saw in the first
my hero academia movie ok so during this
battle all for once somehow managed to
overpower both all my Nana shamora and
prime gran torino all by himself
realizing that they couldn't win nana
shamora pushed all my out of the way
with gran torino then grabbing him and
basically preventing him from going back
to save her which of course he would
have done if he had the choice nana
sacrificed her life so the o'mike could
live and eventually defeat all-4-one in
the future and this is the point where
she utters those famous words I leave
the rest to you
which is quite similar to another moment
we've seen in the show after his master
died all might wanted nothing but
revenge but despite having access to a
hundred percent of one for all he liked
the technique and skilled to defeat all
for one and this is pretty evident in
this scene where all might is getting a
good beatdown in training from Gran
Torino given that all for one was in his
prime at this point he had eyes and ears
all across Japan and would have
eventually found all might because of
this Gran Torino ordered all might to go
to the USA and train there after he
graduated that way he could return to
Japan when he was skillful and strong
enough to defeat all-4-one before he
left though he adopted his masters
trademark smile which would eventually
become his own and he shaped his hair
into the style that we've all grown to
love some of us more than others after
reaching America or might immediately
began hero duties and on one occasion
saved a group of scientists from an
explosion one of which was an
up-and-coming scientist called David
shield this guy then developed a costume
for all my that would become known as
his young age costume the two became
best friends forever and they acted as a
hero team throughout California in fact
it was during this time in America that
all might came up with all the different
names for his moves
for example the Detroit smash all the
famous united states of smash however
his stay in America didn't last forever
and he did in fact return to Japan as we
all know and succeed in his goal to
become this symbol of peace and the best
hero in the world and during this period
of all my rising all for one's influence
dwindled significantly until he became
something that people considered to be a
legend rather than a real existing
threat now at this point almost been a
top hero for many years and he decided
to take on his first true sidekick in
sir Knight I an intelligent guy whose
quirk allows him to see in
the future of specific individuals with
whom he makes eye contact so night I was
actually designed by horikoshi to be a
caricature of a typical Japanese man in
much the same way that all might was
designed to be a caricature of a typical
American superhero which kind of makes
them the best stereotypical duo in the
history of anime all might was at the
peak of his career was working with sir
Knight I but through some unknown means
he eventually came face to face with
all-4-one for the first time since he
was 18 years old and the resulting
battle left them both with life-changing
injuries all might lost his stomach and
his respiratory system was irreparable
damaged meaning that he could no longer
operate at the peak of his power and
despite all that he still came out of
this fight better off
all-4-one had his head completely
crushed and everyone involved believed
that he had died but we know that thanks
to dr. o Jacko
he was able to survive although his new
head looked like an animated potato
torsionally was adamant that he would
still operate as the symbol of peace as
he believed that new villains would rise
up to take over ones place however night
I having looked into all my future
revealed that if all might continued on
his current path he would meet an
unspeakably gruesome death in about 6 or
7 years all might accepted this fate as
he believed that if he was to pass down
one for all at that time there would be
just too many dark years whilst his
successor learned to master the power
and if you think about it ultimately all
he wanted was to avoid a return to the
villainous times that he dealt with when
he was a kid now five years later all
might realized that knowledge prediction
about his death was fast approaching and
decided that he had to enlist as a
teacher a UA to kind of find and raise
the next successor as best he could he
spoke with principal nez sue about who
was worthy of succeeding him and taking
the power of one for all - which nezzie
recommended me Ryota Garza but we all
know what happens next
as a quick sidenote national his son's
name was Katara and if you want to know
exactly how he turned out after she died
check out this video I made breaking
down the origin story of sugar Aki and
there you have it guys that was
everything we know about all meit's
backstory up until the first episode of
my ear academia peace out and I'll catch
you next time
you